hola buenos días gracias por estar aquí
nervioso
bueno porque ocurre cuando vamos a ver
una película animación
y recuerdo cuando era pequeño mi abuelo
nos contaba a mi hermano a mí historias
y cuentos y justo antes de que empezara
a hablar
nuestra mente estaba dispuesta a crear
mundos y personajes fantásticos era
nuestra imaginación que se estaba
preparando para convertir en reales esas
historias y cautivar nuestra atención
durante esos momentos
bueno ya me voy
[Risas]
hace hace hace unos años tuve la
oportunidad de dirigir unos proyectos en
en asia y recuerdo un día mis compañeros
me invitaron a un festival que había en
la plaza de la ciudad cuando llegamos
allí estaba lleno de gente de todas las
edades y todos los estratos sociales y
al cabo de un rato la gente empezó a
aplaudir no y por una de la plaza
entregó una especie de procesión de
gigantes y cabezudos hechos de forma muy
rudimentaria
un recuerdo llevaba una especie de traje
de malla amarilla con los parches
marrones y una cabeza en forma de jirafa
hecha de cartón piedra y unos zancos de
empalme otro llevaba una cola de trapo
verde y una cabeza también de cartón
piedra de dinosaurio
y yo con mi bueno
con mi mente de blanco occidental lo
primero que pensé
tampoco es pasando en mi barrio los
hacen mucho mejores
pero al mismo tiempo que pensaba eso me
avergoncé tremendamente en mi propio
pensamiento al ver la cara de asombro de
fascinación de la gente a mi alrededor
de todas las edades gentes niños gente
mayor gente de mi edad veían a aquella
jirafa como si fuera una jirafa de carne
y hueso y aquel dinosaurio como si
hubiera acabado servirlo en jurásico
me entristece tremendamente me di cuenta
que había perdido mi capacidad de
asombrarme de asombrarme con las cosas
sencillas como cuando mi abuelo nos
contaba las historias de pequeños
desde entonces es parte de mi camino
trato de día a día tratar de volver a
ser capaz de asombrarme de esas cosas
sencillas
con el tiempo uno se hace mayor
ya ya no corremos alocadamente por la
calle sin sentido solo por el gusto de
correr
seguimos seguimos soñando seguimos
teniendo ilusiones pero
aquella ilusión que teníamos de pequeños
parece que la vamos perdiendo yo no
estoy de acuerdo creo que no debe ser
así el hecho de que llevemos traje y nos
convirtamos en personas respetables
no va en detrimento de eso no creo que
en ningún sitio está escrito eso
en animación
lo que intentamos es precisamente jugar
con esa imaginación
esas historias que leíamos escuchábamos
de pequeños toman vida
es como como si nuestra mente
y estuviera dispuesto a crear ese mundo
fantástico
un mundo lleno de historias
extraordinarias
pero por qué no convertir las historias
cotidianas en extraordinarias
han probado ustedes alguna vez en su
vida en tomar una decisión importante en
su vida como si estuvieran escribiendo
el guión de una película en la que
ustedes son los protagonistas y tienen
que decidir qué tiene que hacer el
protagonista para que esta historia sea
interesante sea emocionante
debe el protagonista de esta historia
seguir luchando por la chica que ama en
contra de toda lógica pronosticó
con el riesgo de convertirse en la
persona más estúpida del universo
o sencillamente rendirse y olvidarla
cambia nuestra decisión si estamos
hablando una película animación una
primera ficción nuestra propia vida
mi nombre es a dor si no soy el director
y coguionista de la película buñuel en
el laberinto las tortugas
una película de animación que se
estrenará el próximo 26 de abril y que
contra todo pronóstico el pasado 20 de
octubre ganó el premio especial del
jurado en el festival en emisiones filme
los ángeles
y luego ven veintipico años casi treinta
años trabajando en el mundo de la
emoción y trabajado alrededor del mundo
para compañías como disney donde
dibujamos los personajes a mano o
recientemente para películas como el
libro de la selva o piratas del caribe
donde trabajamos con imágenes generadas
por ordenador
la nuestra es una película sencilla de
un presupuesto humilde pero de las que
se dibujan a mano
y hablan sobre el rodaje del documental
las hurdes tierra sin pan de luís buñuel
en 1932
pero sobre todo es una historia de
amistad es una historia de amistad entre
luís buñuel y ramón acín ramón acín un
artista de la época no muy conocido
desgraciadamente pero era un hombre que
tenía el corazón del tamaño de la
provincia de huesca su tierra natal
y cuando a louis no había manera que
encontrara dinero para hacer su película
le dice un día no te preocupes louis si
me toca la lotería y yo te pago el
documental
y efectivamente a las tres o cuatro
semanas le toca la lotería y ramón
cumple su palabra y le financia el
documental
cosa sorprendente desde el punto de
vista de hoy en día no
hacer esta película en animación nos
permitió llevar al espectador que el
espectador creará en su mente un mundo
diferente un mundo de otra época un
mundo donde la gente pensaba diferente
donde los valores eran diferentes
de esta manera le ofrecimos al
espectador una experiencia diferente
poco habitual en el cine
en 1930 cuando se estrenó la das de oro
un cineasta y fotógrafo francés llamado
eli lotar le ofrece a luis buñuel un
tratado de un hispanista francés francis
también llamado maurice legendre
contratado a unas 300 y pico páginas
sobre una zona de españa llamada las
hurdes
una zona donde se conocía como al
panadero a la persona que iba a mendigar
mendrugos de pan a otros pueblos para
traerlos de vuelta y repartirlos en los
pueblos pobres donde el bocio el
paludismo la consanguinidad y el hambre
estaban a la orden del día
louis termina de rodar el documental
después del verano de 1932 edita lo
edita la cocina de su casa midiendo los
planos con los brazos y mirando los
fotogramas con una simple lámpara nos
contaba a su hijo juan luís que se
descartaron muchos planos porque él se
pensaba que estaban desenfocados
pero desgraciadamente la película fue
prohibida por el gobierno de la época
porque decían que esa pobreza no existía
el cine de luís siempre fue un cine que
pretendía provocar que pretendía que el
espectador pensase
que no dejara las cosas por sentadas
que se las cuestionarse
con las hurdes louis puso a la pantalla
algo que la gente de aquella época no
estaba acostumbrada a ver
en aquella a quien iba al cine la
burguesía la gente que tenía un poco de
dinero y lo que querían era ver sus
historias querían ver a ellos mismos
pero louis les pone algo en la pantalla
que no quieren ver le da voz a quien no
la tiene y les muestra un sufrimiento
que está a 300 kilómetros de madrid y
que nadie hace absolutamente nada
fue prohibida en españa fue prohibida en
muchos sitios
me pregunta a veces después de haber
trabajado en esta película
y ya sé que después de la conferencia
que ha habido quizás suena muy
políticamente correcto lo que voy a
decir
realmente me sorprende la indignación
que a veces tenemos
con el maltrato que solo nos indignemos
cuando vemos el maltrato animal cuando
vemos un burro peleado oa un perro
abandonado
y no hacemos nada cuando vemos a niños
en los barrios marginales de nuestras
ciudades rebuscar entre la basura algo
que echarse a la boca
es que hemos perdido o sea se nos ha
hecho la piel tan dura que ya no
sentimos nada del sufrimiento ajeno
yo creo que no es así yo creo que con el
tiempo cuando nos vamos vamos creciendo
vamos creando alrededor nuestro una
especie de caparazón una cáscara que nos
protege de las cosas que nos lleven
pero acabamos metidos dentro como hacen
las tortugas
entonces cómo es posible volver a
recuperar esta ilusión o esa capacidad
de asombrarnos de las cosas
hay que ser valientes hay que asomar la
cabeza y mirar a los demás
mira los demás a los ojos y entender a
los demás
en esta película lo que intentábamos o
lo que hemos intentado es que la gente
entendiera la mente de louis de la misma
manera que cuando nosotros vemos a los
demás
seamos capaces de entender por qué
actúan de esa manera y para entenderlo
tenemos que conocerlos
mucha gente actúa de manera que a
nosotros nos parecen muy mal
porque sencillamente tienen miedos o
angustias que a lo mejor son frutos de
su pasado y que nada tienen que ver con
nosotros
lo cual al final
yo creo que es tan sencillo como
preguntar empezar con una simple sonrisa
me sorprende muchas veces yo recuerdo
una de las primeras veces que viví fuera
y vine a españa
cuando yo sonreía sencillamente por el
mero hecho de sonreír a alguien en el
metro la gente te miraba como diciendo y
este que quiere ahora
porque es una sonrisa es la cosa más
fácil y más gratuita del mundo no cuesta
nada y es una forma para empezar a
conocer a la gente ya preguntar y
interesarnos en las personas antes de
juzgar las con lo cual yo siempre digo
ya sé que es un cliché pero que
realmente para entender a la gente hay
que ponerse en sus zapatos y saber ver
el mundo desde su punto de vista
esto es todo espero que les haya gustado
y muchas gracias
[Aplausos]